well so here we are to present the first
award of the evening which is well I
guess it's not exactly an awesome
responsibility but it's a big deal I
mean we don't want to look stupid or or
missing the cue cards or looks like
we've never seen each other before or
anything like that right well I I think
they know we've seen each other before
dear why don't you just take a couple of
deep breaths and try and relax and
pretend you're in Lamaze class or
something
no I'll be fine and let's just give the
award okay yeah
it's particularly appropriate that the
award is for the supporting actress
because well it's face it I have
supported one or two actresses in the
past yeah and one or two have supported
you
okay I am I don't think anybody really
wants to hear about that right now I did
well I don't think well I do I want to
know I I mean what's the matter it
scared him with you billion people out
there honey
well I'll tell you what after the show
I'll take you out to the supermarket
we'll buy a few magazines and you can
read all about it how I lived in a UFO
for six years how in a former life you
were an Bolin and how our household pets
have all gotten literary agents and are
telling our secret story from the point
of view of the foot of the bed okay in
the meantime why don't we read the list
no thank you
I'm the nominees for Best Performance by
an actress in a supporting role and my
wonderfully talented colleagues from
working girl Joan Cusack
from the accidental tourist Geena Davis
from Mississippi Burning Frances
McDormand from Dangerous Liaisons
Michele
also from work and girls Sigourney
Weaver
and the Oscar goes to Geena Davis the
accidental
thank you well I sure can't believe I
have to go first I'm very thrilled I
think first of all I should thank and
Tyler for writing such wonderful book
and yeah and after that pretty much
everything else I think goes to my dear
friends Larry Kasdan and Bill hurt and
let's see I'd love to like to thank Ruth
Meyers our wonderful costume designer
David iDEN Berg and Susan Geller my my
wonderful acting coach Roy London and my
my other wonderful acting coach and
darling husbands Jeff Goldblum thank you
to all the members of Academy